damnit Daenerys Nikolaj coster-waldau
but you don't like when I say that cuz
you think I'm gonna say dammit you've
spoiled him he's gonna cuddle that you
need after all this
you're going to advise me advise you on
what how to get what I want the Iron
Throne perhaps you should try wanting
something else as we going to seasoning
who do you think that deserves the Iron
Throne I mean I do
dammit Daenerys ya know whatever all the
other people who deserve it more but no
I'm gonna say the mother a dragon
instead gathered right I will dedicate
myself to seeing you on the Iron Throne
because I choose you my Khalifa felici I
was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
Nikolaj coster-waldau not Jaime
Lannister coster-waldau deserves the
Iron Throne
ho hold on you can't hold on yeah but
they could still deserve it hold on I
suppose you could go back and change
time couldn't ya yeah
dammit you've spoiled it totally but
that's not what happened is it he needs
to know the truth I was given to Brienne
of Tarth because I think she's a very
strong noble person and Westeros
deserves that I'm shoot your back and
keep your counsel and give my life for
yours if need be I think Sansa but you
don't like when I say that cuz you think
I'm gonna say so I keep thinking she's
gonna say sound remember oh really and
then he's not that at all but I think I
think everybody's got their pluses and
their minuses nobody deserves it
outright I wasn't sure if you'd remember
me
Samwell Tarly really yeah he's just the
one that you want to just yeah it's a
good thing the best guys he's gonna
cuddle you a good man oh thank you you
need after all this [ __ ] yeah it's just
a good person he has a sense of humor
he's warm he's a beast and pathetic he's
he's funny
he's not arrogant arrogant he's got it
all from now on wherever you go I go too
I'm gonna say donate I mean I don't want
to say Danny cuz it feels like she's the
one that's put the most effort into
you're like if you were looking at like
a political campaign mmm she's put in
the hard yards but she actually has a
claim to it so I probably saved Jon Snow
however I should really say Gendry this
I know but I'd like to see Tyrion on
there because I think he'd probably do
the best job given what he's been
through I think you'd be interested to
see what he made about Ned Stark Johnson
don't know he saw something in John and
now we've all seen it - surprised you
didn't see Jon Snow no I think that I
think that starts should have had it's
in the beginning listen to me all right
it's only because you've done more
seasons yeah who deserved it
the one gets it there's only one reward
I want I don't think anyone deserves it
I think everyone just needs to stop
being so obsessed with this bloody Iron
Throne yeah there's so much more to this
bloody story yeah I know and it causes
so much conflict and I just think let's
just yeah what cool debates it's just a
nightmare and leave it there you guys
does it matter
sir pounce that's what I'd like to see
Anna everyone's just dead and then sir
pounds just hop sir I don't know that
would be great that's accounts
you